what's up guys my name is Jana welcome
to episode 21 of 3d game programming in
Java alrighty
so last episode I set you guys some
homework and I'm sitting here recording
this episode realizing I haven't checked
that that homework so I'm not sure if
anyone completed it but it's kind of a
I'm just gonna take a deep breath and
say that your homework has been forgiven
you ahh just this once
because I I don't know I started
recording at night I just realized that
I didn't check it out anyway that's all
the point point is we're gonna continue
on with walls and stuff like this this
episode you can probably read it in the
title I usually like to say what I'm
going to do in this episode just in case
new people who won't subscribe to me or
whatever stumble upon the video etc etc
alright anyway back to this so at the
moment we've got this right ah and by
this I mean this this like this ok this
mouth I can hang on right so we've got
this thing and it's there's a few
problems with it actually well there's
not really any problems with it there's
just things away well there is one
problem with it but there's also a few
things that we need to add to it to
improve it first of all we need to be
able to add a texture to it currently it
has been formatted in a way that accepts
textures which is good because all we
need to do is apply textures to it now
now a lot of you guys could figure this
out by yourselves like it's easy like
it's literally one line of code and
you've written that line of code before
it's really easy to work out I'll
obviously show you guys how to do it
though but I'll show you guys a
different way of doing it as well so the
first thing we're going to do we're
actually going to do today is texture
this wall into a texture similar like
the floor you know we - actually the
floor we're going to texture this wall
as well into a different texture
obviously the other thing we sort of
have here is this was a space really
this annoying all the time it seems
really look at this it's only been
moving now wow I should fix that
shouldn't I anyway ah we've got this
problem as you can see and it the thing
with this is it's not really look at
that see that it's not clipping
correctly
and that's the problem so we need to be
able to clip this properly for this not
to happen okay because this is obviously
a huge thing whenever it's not so much a
problem there and the reason I say that
is because we're not going to be inside
these walls at any time and you can see
it's happening here as well there's like
it's like doesn't there's a huge amount
of them and you can see that when and
yeah okay so you can see that even
though it like there's a huge dis Mouse
I'm actually going to kill this mouse in
it in a minute just I gotta explain this
first god I just keep rotating left and
right anyway so god the thing is you can
see that all these squares I can't point
my mouse at them I'm pointing my finger
at them right now don't know why but
anyway you can see that all these
squares are like they're a square aspect
ratio they're perfectly square so what
is doing is it's not stretching out the
wall it's just literally multiplying its
duplicating the wall like infinite times
and that's a problem with clipping and
we'll fix that today even though we
don't really need to because it doesn't
happen on this side you can see that if
we go here it sort of just disappears
like it doesn't really happen it only
happens on the the side that is
invisible as you can see but uh that's
all right who flicks it anyway and okay
we're not gonna fix that first thing
we're gonna do is fix this bloody Mouse
I'm about actually I'm actually raging
right now okay I'm sorry um we're gonna
have to go fix it
this snails I never knew that it was
such a problem maybe it's only when I
record I'm not sure but God okay well
okay okay one thing I want to do real
quick actually uh is let me quickly
public static and mouse button um
where's a mouse clicks here it is all
right mouse button equals a to get
button what's called mouse button
nope get button it once get button I was
with a zik right where are we controller
what is it input handler dots mouse
button actually this should be here
there should be here up all right
else just do this damn thing else and
let's just put it here as well all right
so what I've done now is I've said that
if I hit the right mouse button it's
going to actually not rotate there oh
look at me casually casually dragging
that window over to my second monitor as
if I'm well you know you recording both
monitors alright so what is going to do
now is when I click it'll rotate the
mouse and stuff but when I want to show
you guys this I hit the right mouse
button and as you can see it's not going
to rotate so you can see that these
squares I'll be correct aspect ratio so
yeah I'm sorry guys I had to put that in
you don't need to put that into your
game it's kind of useless it's it's
gonna crash
alright I don't think it's actually
going to crash every time we close it no
it's not okay good
you don't actually need to put this into
your game it's kind of useless it's only
good for for debugging like I obviously
removed that I don't want I don't want
to route the right mouse button to
actually just release the whole thing
it's useful when you're trying to close
something or when I'm cuz you could say
that sometimes when I was just trying to
get a good look at the wall I'd try and
hurry up and put my mouse out of there
this is a better fix anyway so now we've
got a nice view about wall that's good
alright so one thing I want to do
actually is fix the mouse sort of um
look at that it's an unbelievable yeah
we will definitely fix up clipping to
that I'll show you guys how to it's not
anyway the point is I want to fix up the
mouse speed so you can see that if we
move it this fast or if we move it this
fast the speed is exactly the same
that's not cool
so I'm going to make a new variable here
I'll call it public static mouse speed
um I'll make it an integer actually
should we make it a double
that's alright oh actually double
probably more exact but we're making it
in phenomenal see how good that is
all right so all I want to do here is
same mouse speed and this is just before
the old X by the way equals our math
naps ABS ABS ABS sensor absolute and
we'll just grab new X and also transform
all dogs
so basically real quick what this is
going to do and I capitalized it there
what this is going to do basically is
it's going to subtract its every time
this updates it's going to figure out
the amount that is changed by so you
know might have changed 30 pixels that
might have changed three hundred pixels
and it's going to figure out that
difference now the reason we use the
reason we don't do this what did I just
do I just hit backspace and it took like
a minute to delete it anyway the reason
we don't do this is because that could
possibly return us a negative value
now what absolute what an absolute value
is is it returns the absolute value of
an int value now basically what that
does is it returns a positive value okay
so in other words if the change if we
move it left that's going to be negative
like 100 pixels right but it's not going
to it's not going to return negative 100
it's going to return 100 positive 100 so
in other words it's this is not nets
them it's never going to give us a
negative value because as you can
imagine the mouse suddenly the mouse
speed suddenly changing to a negative
value is obviously going to be
problematic so that's why we have to use
absolute now the other thing another way
to think that word if you still can't
get it is it's like it's the distance
away
from zero so if zero is right here even
if we're here which is negative 100 the
distance is 100 isn't it so I hope that
helped if it didn't I could foster out
my paint on that and I'm sure you guys
will understand whether with this
because this tool is approved as well
for these tutorials all right so I'll
make a quick a line was it down a line
thing ah doesn't matter we'll just make
a little thing there and we'll fill it
with black I guess alright so if this is
like a Cartesian plane which is like a
thing alright so now that we got this
let's just remove that oh we can't
really move that can we it's gonna
create holes in our thing anyway so
we've got this right so if we've got a
value up here which is 100 right
this right here is zero and this right
here is negative 100 I feel a sneeze
coming on I want to try and hold it in
that's I'm going to work hang on what
whoo all right sorry about that that
probably picked the audio I'm sorry I
might add that out I'll probably want
that because I'm lazy but um anyway
actually there's another one coming on
hang on what I don't know why I'm
sneezing it's like 30 degrees it's like
35 degrees outside and like 30 degrees
inside anyway point is sorry about that
guys is the distance between these two
right is 100 and the distance between
these two is 100 now I feel like a math
teacher doing this because I shouldn't
be explaining this to you guys but I
know that a lot of you really like me to
explain things like this in depth like I
did with cosine and sine and stuff like
that but um the point is let's get rid
of that the point is the apps an
absolute value so math dot apps math
apps actually it's is capitalized no
it's not dammit
screw that off
oh crap anyway a math dot the absolute
value is going to return a positive
value every time and so if you want to
measure something and you want it to
always be positive math dot abs mouth
abs whatever you want something that
returns the absolute value of something
in other words the non a non-negative
number so if it's a negative it will
automatically be give it converted to
negative now what we could have done is
just said that you know if the numbers
negative just times it by negative one
so in other words what we could have
done technically actually let's just
let's just slow down here I'm just
getting excited about this absolute
value stuff ah let's just slow down here
and make this work first and then I'll
show you guys you know I guess another
way of doing it um let's go to
controller and let's see so we got our
mouse for rotation speed and let's just
multiply that by display dot mouse speed
and one other thing we'll do is that's
going to be way too much because it's
you know it's kind of lower so we're
just going to put that to like 0.04 or
something I don't know per se all right
so you can see that we're sort of moving
it slow and the faster we move it the
faster it's going to move now that's
still too fast again second one that I
got to remember that I'm recording ah
true maybe okay so you can see how slow
that is and then you can see that's a
bit faster so this should this should
make it a lot easier to navigate around
the screen so yeah use that okay now my
way not only my way but if math dot ABS
didn't exist what you could have done is
let's just scrap that first of all all
right first of all I just want to see
what this looks like yeah you can see
that if I go negative it's it's going to
go negative which means it'll
essentially be rotating right even
though I'm rotating laughs if even if
even though I'm dragging left so that's
why you need that but what you could
have done is said if mouse speed is less
than zero so if it's negative then Mouse
speed
x equals minus 1 all right and while
that would have done is as you can see
made it so the one you go left it would
work
and that's clipping right there look at
that oh that's gorgeous where's our
actual box here it is why we're on the
wrong side there we go
so yeah that's another way of doing it
right there and I think you guys are
familiar with x equals basically what
that is is it's saying hang on Mouse
speed I know that a lot of you guys I've
actually been asked this so this is this
statement right here is the exact same
as this statement right here all right
so Mouse yep that's basically a short
version of writing that so if I comment
that out prove to you guys you can see
that it's exactly the same as if I am as
if I yeah you know if I did this so yeah
so it's x equals so basically okay I'm
not gonna screw this my explanations
aren't worth it um you guys probably saw
that as I feel like I'm teaching
preschool children who don't don't
understand how numbers work but um
nevertheless abs is therefore at the
absolute value mascot abs is there for
us to use so hey we might as well use it
okay so yeah and you can see that is uh
is awesome and that works all right
anyway so that's a that's a huge
improvement on Mouse on Mouse stuff um
and yeah and that's really easy to do
all right let's get back into like
texture and stuff I'm sorry I did that
in a fit of rage okay I didn't want to
fix a mouse at the moment but I just I
needed to get that out of the way
especially that right-click stuff helps
me explain but anyway the point is we've
got this it looks nice
let's go and actually talk about
textures now so in case you guys I
didn't pick up by how I what I said in
the beginning which was on how easy it
wasn't we've done before let's find the
code where we applied the texture this
texture
and again I can I'm so happy I can just
right-click now and actually use the
mouse pointer to show you guys what's up
you can see that
hang on was I saying yeah let's find the
code where we actually applied this
texture to the floor hey look there it
is
okay so this texture that we've applied
to the floor cool it's literally as
simple as going ctrl C and let's go down
to the pixels thing where we applied the
texture to this thing and let's just
comment that out I want to save this
line at all I want to save this line of
code for now let's just hit OK except
let's replace of Y texture with instead
of wipe X and X texture set of expects
Oh check that out we've got the same
texture on the on the walls now that
with the same texture as we did on the
floor so isn't that spectacular you can
see now if we clip it and I can oh god
that was the best thing I've ever done
made that right click stop rotating so
now I can use the mouse point I'm so
happy anyway you can see that what
that's done is the clipping it's
literally just duplicating it like
infinite time space but I don't know if
it's infinite but it's looks that way
we'll fix that as well I'm just making
sure you guys understand right so that's
all cool but the problem here is that um
we don't want to use the same texture
right I know you guys are saying what I
don't want to use the same texture there
in there so you don't have to okay you
can make a new texture which one want to
do now enter folder so let's go to our
resources our textures and let's check
out our floor texture so this is our
floor everything seems to open on my
other wanted when I'm recording anyway
you can see our floor texture that's
wonderful now in game programming
there's something called a sprite sheet
and then I'm going to teach you guys how
to do that right now so we've sort of
confined our game at the moment to 8x8
and I'm not going to change that I've
already said that before I'm not gonna
change it until a later episode
hmm sorry um anyway yeah so it's 8 by 8
pixels at moment awesome so if we make
another one it'll be 8 by 8 as well so
having knowing that I'm having that in
mind we can open this where the pen out
of course and let's do that first we can
say something let's go to image canvas
size I don't know if you guys are using
paint on that but it's pretty much
everywhere if you're using Photoshop
it's something canvas size as well I
don't know I don't remember what it is
anyway let's just increase the width 216
right so now we've got doubled with now
what we'll do is let's just select this
area here which is 8 by 8 so in other
words I've selected it which means that
the only area I can edit isn't out that
area so I can't touch this pick this
texture because I don't want to at the
moment let's say I'm just going to
select two colors here maybe like a
light sort of teal ish color and a and
just a nice a nice blue color it's like
a royal blue I'm gonna grab a drag over
a gradient maybe even like the other way
or something I don't know that teal
colors sort of isn't what I was looking
for maybe like like a greenish color
sort of looks like the ocean I know but
um it doesn't matter for the purposes of
a tutorial yeah so I think that looks an
Al's nice I like the blue maybe the
green sort of is reminiscent of the
current state of the game before I
invoked this because it's blonde green
but um
again that right-click is amazing anyway
uh but that looks kinda nice anyway so
we'll leave it at that
now what we've done is we've essentially
created a new texture let's save it ctrl
s mm-hmm
file save however you want to do it
anyway that's one important point is
that uh we've got two textures now like
in one thing and because we're only
using 8x8 textures we can say that ok
this is one texture right now this is
another texture apply the second texture
to the the walls and keep the first
texture for the floor now how do we do
that easy check this out this what is
the location of this currently
horizontally it's
Plus eight pixels in it if we even look
at paint.net here I don't know if you
guys can see this if you're watching in
a 1080p full screen on like a 1080p
resolution monitor you'll probably be
able to see it it says that as our
selection top level is eight by zero
which means that we are we've gone eight
pixels X on the x-axis and zero pixels
on the y-axis which means the location
of this right here the starting
coordinate over here is eight because
we're a well obviously eight pixels
across because this takes up eight
pixels one two three four five six seven
eight eight it's actually zero one two
but anyway eight so what we have to do
is say okay ignore the first eight
pixels horizontally just go on from
eight pixels um horizontally just go on
from here and just select this I'm not
sure if I'm explaining this correctly I
don't actually rehearse my tutorial so I
don't I don't even think about how I'm
going to explain the point is we've got
this let's save it and oldsman to my
sister guess we need it again and let's
just delete this line now this X set now
and I don't want to delete I'll just
comment it out again and instead of
we've got this wonderful set up here but
instead of having this here okay
actually one thing we need to do now
just to not cause errors in the future
it is times eight is sort of indicating
the width of our image not really the
width it's more like the width and
height of our image so what we need to
do is say that it's 16 now because
that's the size of this we need to say
16 because you notice if I even leave it
a date even though I haven't done
anything if I run it like I haven't done
anything at all if I run it you'll see
that well it's like it's all screwed up
right now it's it looks like and they're
clipping I want to feel silent and I
have to fix that today it's not hard to
fix don't worry you can see that it's
sort of combining both textures it's
only working and the reason for that is
that it's not 16 so we need to change
the 8 to 16 why because the width this
is 16 simples that if you made the width
32 you've made for textures here one for
each side of the wall or whatever I
don't know um then you have to make it
you have to make it 32 okay it's as
simple as that
16 so
let's just leave that at it and you can
see now that well you can see now that
our floors fine but this is still not
good because we've left at it keep on
right-clicking on stuff because we've
left it on um what he call it
we've left it on Nate so let's go back
and change this to 16 as well not set
buffer this and you'll see that okay
awesome we've got a 16 size texture and
everything's working properly as it
seems now how do we tell it to go 8
pixels left easy ok ok this is X right
and this is why again I feel I don't
know why I have this thing in my head
telling me that I'm teaching people who
don't understand simple things but
anyway the point is that you might not
understand this hopefully one of some of
you don't so I don't look like an idiot
explain in this tutorial this is X and
this is y alright so we're going on X
we're saying it's 8 pixels from X if we
okay we could have also placed this
extra below it and it would and it would
work perfectly as well by the way I'll
keep that in mind as well but then that
would be y plus 8 this is X plus 8
because 8 is on the X it's we move this
X we move these eight on the x axis so
let's go back here and add 8 to the X
texture whole thing leave that answer
than that's a bit modifier bitwise
operator we want to leave that there
let's just add it right right here like
that let's run it magic magic it's there
suddenly alright so now you can see that
we are we're going in plus 8 right here
it's it's that simple feel like I'm
still feel like I'm selling like a
product here it's that simple to do it
with this product anyway if we added 8
here as well so plus 8 so at the other
bracket then it would change everything
to this and obviously if we did not
eight at 8 here then it would
would make it basically the other way
around here anyway the point is that
that's how you sort of play around with
with spreadsheets and and how you have
multiple touches in one file
it's obviously advantageous if you have
low resolution textures to have multiple
dashes in one file and certainly many
indie games minecraft does that as you
guys know a lot of Java games do that
flash game - that the tons of basically
little games do that because when
textures are low resolution is basically
a lot better to pack all your I don't
know all the all of your massive number
of eight textures into a into like a 64
by 64 so as I don't know basically into
it into a I'm into one file instead of
having separate files for each of those
textures obviously if the textures are
like 1024 by 1024 resolution and they're
really high res for like I don't know
Skyrim or something then you'd obviously
put them in different files and
obviously also if you're texturing
things other than cubes so if you're
dashing like a sword I don't know I'm
just thinking Skyrim here if you're
testing a sword then you'd have to
obviously use a 3d program probably to
to actually honor up the UVW mapping for
that and sort of do that I'm up and go
into that you guys if you guys are like
3d models and animators whatever
renderers you will understand what I
mean but otherwise for cubes instead of
these sprite sheets right
simples that low resolution square
textures use spreadsheets right now
we're 25 minutes this is not going to be
like 56 minutes like the other tutorial
was the other tutorial was pretty insane
that's because it was big it was long
there was a lot of stuff to do but here
let's just talk about fixing this now
what we're going to do simply here is
we're actually going to actually going
to set up like a whole like clipping
like thing but to do that we need to
sort of talk about clipping textures
correctly so at the moment I want to
leave this here now this probably won't
change anything at the moment but you'll
see that if we go down here into our
tech stuff you'll see this these are
sort of like this sort of like a text
texture modifiers and I don't know what
to call the - I call this one I'm gonna
make them variables I'm
call this one text 3-0 and text for zero
because there's a reminiscent of this so
this is zero and this is eight let's
create those variables roundabout well
way too high
roundabout here so after our main stuff
so double oh my goodness
double text three zero equals that
equals zero and double text four zero
equals eight
so we should get Santa changed obviously
we just made them variables having that
done as well the other thing I want to
do is create a double and we'll call it
a clip and this is going to be the
amount I'll go to clip so it's going to
be zero pointer for now we'll play
around with that number actually the
set-off was 0.5 so what happens right
and let's go into the actual algorithm
now so basically what we want to say is
if our rotation left side Z is less than
our clip amount then arm actually let's
all right
that is capitalized let's do let's do
that first so we'll make another double
within here we'll call it a we're going
to call it the reason I want to make
another double is because to actually
simplify this for you guys because it's
going to be okay let's ignore that
double for now so rotation left side it
said it's going to equal rotation left
side Z plus rotation right side said -
rotation - rotation
what is it off size that obviously
just trying to remember those variables
um so yeah bluffed my outsides that
awesome what else do we need to do we
need to divide that obviously by our
whole clipping deal
- rotation left side said hang on not /
/ never multiply it by that and Alan is
quite in a bit let me just type it out
first and we'll divide that here by
rotation right side Z - obviously
rotation will rotation left side Z all
right
so awesome um save that I guess that's
you can save that sort of heated up
not really we'll talk about in a bit so
yeah that's the Cowan Sutherland
algorithm for you guys
yeah and they can see why I wanted to UM
that's okay so I've got this say we're
gonna have to apply the same thing to
that which is what I wanted to make that
variable I'm actually going to go ahead
and do it now I will call it um I'm
going to call it out in our clip I call
a cold clip but clips already been taken
I don't want to cause any conflicts here
so call it clip zero clip Sarah alright
um oh yeah what one more thing actually
I should probably mention this a lot of
you okay not a lot of you but some of
you guys have been posting comments
saying that I'm sealing code from notch
et cetera et cetera I don't want to
really get into that because most of you
guys are just trolling um what I just
want to make it clear to you guys if you
aren't already not didn't invent that
code like this is Java
this is graphics programming this is
this isn't even Java this is graphics
programming this is just a war this is
just me basically converting this into
Java for you guys but it's the same in
every programming language it's this is
how you clip alright now I don't know if
I can find it Cohen's little an
algorithm because this is what is called
I'll try and search it up here on
Wikipedia say Cohen son
oh and Sutherland line clipping
algorithm and seven of the citrus here
it is I heard this awesome visible
Kapiti page on it there we go alright so
here's another sort of lecture for you
guys
the Cohen Sutherland algorithm is
basically it's a line clipping algorithm
which divides a 2d space into nine
regions so if I I don't know a line
clipping might have yeah it's got an
image fantastic so you can see that
basically is dividing into one two three
one two three four five six seven eight
nine regions where the center point
middle is things that don't get clipped
so if we're outside it gets clipped but
here it doesn't get clipped now if an
object is the same move object and it
goes outside the whole object gets click
gets clipped unless we actually add in
this code so in other words what I'm
going to do here is Milanoo solve
clipping but the point is this is okay
this is so this isn't c / c++ bits
virtually the same as java and there we
go you can see right here let me just
bring that up you can see right here
let's just let's just keep this here
that up if we're looking at this car do
that um we've got our entire thing like
worked out here look up take this out so
we've got x0 plus x1 minus x0 so
rotation so rotation left side Z equals
rotation left side Z right x0 plus
rotation right side - rotation left side
said x1 minus x0 times now it actually
times a clip so x by y max which is like
a clipping amount minus y0 so rotation
left side Zed and / / radiation right
side Zed - British on left like that so
you can see that you know like this is
that this is like an old this is like a
huge like algorithm it's existed for a
long time if you if you guys have done a
lot of I don't know graphics programming
I don't think a lot of you guys have I
guess I thought I probably wouldn't be
watching this tutorial
um
like you probably would have heard of
this um but the point is like there's a
like well-known out there's a well known
algorithms like a lot of people use this
stuff so if I'm using like some of the
code they're not uses it's because first
of all I think that this way like this
sort of like game engine that is created
or what it is you know compiled
basically um is is probably the best way
to make a 3d first-person shooter
without using OpenGL or the graphics
card this is why this is running at 42
your frames per second if I put this
onto it on total graphics I'd be running
at 5,000 frames per second but that's
not that's not the point the point is
that like just remember that okay please
I don't want any more comments saying
I'm stealing code from knife I am using
some of notches code I mentioned that
earlier most of it though is as you can
see it's generic code that famous people
wrote not that notches and famous
obviously but my point is actual
graphics program is broke anyway let's
just stop talking about that and get
back to this so we're not done here
obviously um so we've done that awesome
let's do the same thing let's just copy
and paste up and I'm gonna make some
room here because there's no room here
did I actually what that wouldn't have
no that didn't good let's so I just
copied and pasted that and now let's do
the same thing for X so let's just
replace basically everything with with X
it's that simple X X X X and obviously
clip 0 is going to say the same let's
save that and what else ah yeah and I
want to do the texture fixing up thing
as well so that's going to be text and
yeah it's going to use it it's going to
use the same method it's going to be the
actual variable plus the other variable
subtracted from the variable that we've
just done in brackets and then multiply
that by clip 0 alright so we've done the
left side let's do the right side now as
well so let's copy
and paste this except will obviously
have to change everything now to right
side and actually before I go ahead and
change everything you can say that that
actually did something when I hit
control s but before I do that let's
just make sure that if we've already
clipped it isn't Club it anymore so
basically we want to say that if if this
is less than or basically if it this is
just a protected from not working so in
other words if this is less than that
clip and our our right side is less than
that clip so only that clip what am i
typing clip I called is that clip in the
on the MA scratch code whatever you
wanna call it in my notes I will return
so it may just make sure that we've
already like clipped it if it's just
going on basically prevent errors in the
code fact that both our left and right
side are less than 0.5 for any reason
right anyway let's go on to the right
side so make sure this is right make
sure this is right we're going to
actually have to probably change it to
just about everything will still give
this actually that's pretty much all we
have to change yeah let's save it all
right you can see how that totally just
got rid of our clubbing so yeah you can
see that that is the corner that's the
corner and the clipping is just simply
not there it's fixed and hopefully if we
go this side as well where are we hell
are we
you can see that it seems to be working
perfectly which is cool all right
anyway that's probably just about all I
want to cover this tutorial so we fixed
a bunch of graphical sort of problems
you can see that the clipping a now is
gone yeah you can see that we're not
getting that stuff again in the future
will obviously make this collision like
math basically so what that means is and
you can see that even if we're here you
know like we're pretty go actually the
pics of the textures do this so let's
try it
try um let's try not include the texture
stuff see if that actually feels it oh
it does okay that's weird
ah really hmm that is weird anyway ah
for the most part it works um just make
sure that I've been missing anything
anyway so for the most part it's it's
working right now and yeah alright
actually someone in the a lot of people
in the comments actually I'm forget who
I'm sorry again I shouldn't do this
shooter I should actually find out who
um hang on let me just find that video
okay where are we
what was that episode 20 let's just
yield comments real quick alright um why
is that
anyway 0.625 contrived zero points yeah
so the computer man 97 oh I don't know
if he was the first one to I'm not gonna
read all the comments right now I show
you I I have maybe dammit here we go so
the computer man 97 suggested that we
try 0.0625 because it's one sixteenth
let's try that out and actually think of
that while I was playing around with
this so let's go to it's actually in
render is now let's try six five for the
correction and save that uh makes it
better
oh okay not exactly actually yeah
not exactly I'm gonna say that 0.062 are
sorry my bad 65 is that pretty good
that looks pretty good
all right well we'll go with the
computer man 97 at the moment and we'll
go we'll roll with 0.0625 at the moment
because that seems to be a good I guess
anyway I'm not going to install any
longer that's the end of this tutorial
so to recap we've done the mouse right
we've improved the mouse what we what
else have we done we've we've text
clipping prop we've done clipping
properly so it doesn't actually do that
do that stuff like it did last time and
we one other thing oh we just did
directly that stuff's not really
important though Oh
we added textures right I thought that
was the important one we are we added a
texture to our wall so that's what we
did today okay save yours last time 100
likes on this video guys and I will
release the next episode we never fail
to do it anyway so I don't think we've
we've never felt that no episode has
been delayed because of the fact that we
can reach a hundred likes which is why
I'm raising the bar 200 likes that's
right I did it
okay 200 likes on this video and I will
release episode 22 one day earlier
alright Saturday now I'm going to regret
saying this tomorrow but right now I am
going to release episode 21 22 a day
earlier if I if this video gets 200
likes and if he gets 150 likes then I'll
release it at all because if it gets
less 150 life so I'm not gonna release
the next episode but if he goes if it
gets over 200 likes and I'm going to
release it one day earlier so that's my
little contract deal with you guys um
for eclipse is up I want to get you guys
more excited for level uh level 22
episode 22 I think that first of all
we'll fix this
this knowledge will we'll sort out this
non-existence of these things from this
angle but our more importantly where is
it keep losing a damn it do I keep
running through it just look like
running there it is I keep running
through it but I can't see it because
yeah all right but I think I think we're
ready to do this
what we'll do is we'll actually probably
randomize a number of these around the
screen so that we'll make like a maze
through which we can walk through how
about that how's that sound so 200 likes
and we'll do that all right
200 likes like the video it's not hard
it's a once one button come on and and
that's it
so I will see you guys later and yeah
later guys bye
you